so when i remember asking her i asked
her out on the stairs
she said yes and i ran away as soon as
she said yes i was like gang and
ran away
[Music]
what is that i don't know how it goes
it's my fault
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's my fault it's my fault i wear my
heart on my sleeve
her has been broke many times
[Laughter]
when she says she likes white guys oh
that's funny
when she says she only dates white guys
that's the funniest thing it's my
fault all right um
here we are again guys welcome
um kick this mule bro what's up kick
this jump
yeah kick this meal there's a podcast i
listen to a guy called joey diaz he's
the funniest
oldest most racist guy ever but he's i
like him because like he's one of those
guys he'll never get cancelled
because he is
so unapologetically himself that is just
like
we know what to expect like if you're
listening to him you know what he's like
so if you listen to him you know
you can't be outraged because everything
out of his mouth is like that you're
just like
i'm never gonna change him let's just
leave him and he's funny
but like yeah just him yeah he does a
podcast just see me he has like a
producer that he talks to but it's
mainly just him
okay and he's funny brav um
yeah he's hilarious but yeah he at the
start of his podcast all the time
his producer called lee and then he'll
always be like lee
kick this [ __ ] mule and then
they'll put on like one old song
like it could be like michael jackson it
could be black sabbath it could be
anything he loves like retro [ __ ] okay
and he's like in his 50s
okay lee kick this [ __ ] mule
and then they'll play one banger
so it's the sickest way to start a
[ __ ] glass ever six it gases me every
time it's a different energy you really
don't know what to expect
and he likes all sorts yeah like he
could just come with like rappers
delight one day and just be like and he
knows the history of that music
okay he always knows like this is it
1979.
oh i said it in my [ __ ] he's got a
proper husky voice sitting in my [ __ ]
room listen to this
and i was just thinking [ __ ] i want to
[ __ ] snort some coke and [ __ ] and
eat some [ __ ] and stuff like that like
he's
mad for it [ __ ] it he's a sick guy
joey diaz joey coco diaz as they say um
yes anyway kick this [ __ ] mule
bro what you got for me
um so fun fact of the day do you know on
capitol capital on lowercase i's and
lowercase js
you know the dot so the dot is called
the title
t-i-t-t-l-e and it's derived from
it's derives from the phrase to a t
so when you do something to a t that
means you're doing something
like let's say i'm copying you i'm
copying you to a t it's derived from the
phrase copying you to a title so in the
sense that
you're doing everything exactly i don't
know why it's called a title but it's
called
that's that's what it's called that's
interesting the small dot on caps on
lowercase is a lowercase js
it's called a title t-i-t-t-l-e i'll bet
my life savings
that i haven't put a dot on top on top
of a j or an i
in the last 15 years
i think i write in all caps anyway i
always write in all caps i write in all
caps anyway i think
i think i do yeah i've not written in
ages mostly in caps and but there's some
letters i think i do in lower case
like m's i do lowercase m's i don't and
sometimes i'll do lowercase e sometimes
i'll do a capital e it's all [ __ ] up
so if anyone's reading my [ __ ]
i always write they must be like [ __ ]
this guy this guy's a prick they must
look at some if someone
saw my hand writing they would think i'm
a prick because it's all over the place
it's a shambles i remember oh my god my
handwriting back in the day was
horrendous
i used to hold a pen oh i wish i had a
pen on me right now i used to hold a pen
in like between my middle finger and my
wedding finger
oh jesus yeah that's how i used to i
used to hold it in between here
and i was thinking what the [ __ ]
obviously now i write so you would you
claw around it like that
but i've got a pen yeah
possibly that so i used to hold a pair
like this before
oh wow obviously now i hold like that
yeah and i used to hold a pen like
i just told a pair like that so i meant
claw it over that's [ __ ] up that is
[ __ ]
my hand
i hold my pen in a weird way people
always cut me from my pen but i don't
know what's weird about it so i hold it
so if i'm writing it i hold it like that
i think that's how my sister holds it
yeah so if i'm yeah if i'm writing i'll
hold it like that and everyone's like
how can you hold your pen i don't know
my pops used to cuss my handwriting he
used to tell me you're going to sit here
and write until your handwriting gets
better there was a problem
i don't know why i can't remember
obviously i know why i can't remember
when rather
he didn't predict the future very well
did he hand right was terrible
handwriting is so
irrelevant now it's so irrelevant now
but then if i write a birthday card i
get a cramp in my hand
i don't write anymore exactly i get a
crumb in my hand just from writing a
little birthday card
i'm getting from thinking about it a
birthday card bruv that's hilarious
but yeah man you said you had uh
something oh yeah
so hold on hold on i forgot about that i
need to find it
i need to find it my heart's been broke
so many times
i don't know what to believe it's going
to be a good one as well because i feel
like the person
asked he said he dm'd us individually to
ask us for our advice
on something jesus this is something did
i air him or what
wait don't where do you air tonight is
irrelevant because you'll be able to
answer it now cool do you know what i
mean
fair play biggest computers are nice
i'm a busy guy second biggest podcast
tonight yeah so i'll just read out the
thing
hi but listening to the podcast for time
i'm in a bit of a situation
and could do with your opinion this was
time ago as well so i don't know whether
he's dealt with it or not
long story short i've been talking to
this girl i think it's probably gonna go
somewhere but it's slow
i met this other girl at a party about a
week after
and i just did dm me he did dm i replied
it i replied it but i don't i don't
remember what i replied so he's
basically fresh again
okay i met this other girl at a party
about a week after and i started talking
to the first one
and she's and i started talking to the
first one and she's all for
it she's two years older than me and i
saw her
and another what she's two years older
than me
and i saw her and another and think
the week up like he's english yeah his
grammar's all over the gaff
so i think he's saying i saw her she's
two years older than me and i saw the
first one and i saw the other one a week
after
yeah that's what he's trying to say and
we were all over each other basically
basically she wants to meet up and do it
but i don't know if
i said i wouldn't be he said that's how
i know he's young basically
she wants to meet me and do it and i
don't know if i would be in the wrong
when i'm talking to this first girl from
before and i see it going somewhere
also to make things worse if i went for
it
we'd have to do it in the back of the
car that's what made that's what
sweetened me
as there as there's no other way there's
no other place for us to go at that time
and it would be his first time
i guess it would be an experience what
would you have done in my situation and
he said i'm 18 in two weeks so he's 18
now because this was a while ago
he said and then he then messaged me
saying i asked james as well but i
wanted two opinions
so you tell me what you would have given
up if you remember the advice so
remember watch me give him now the
complete
opposite advice so i gave him at the
time i'm awful um
right i remember the the car bit
yeah so i'm pretty sure okay cool
i'm pretty sure i told him if the
if the new the older one that he wants
to [ __ ] that wants to do it that one
stuff like him
yeah that wants to [ __ ] him as long as
he makes his intentions clear
that he's just trying to bust these nuts
then i don't really see much
issue there's no there's not in my
opinion there's not nothing really wrong
with talking to two girls
he can see something happening with this
other girl
but if that if we're not there yet then
and you're making your intentions
as long as you're not [ __ ] with two
people's heads like as long as you're
telling everyone what it is
like if you see a future with this one
let that be known
if you just want to [ __ ] this one let
that be known and if all parties are
consenting
then do your thing and then i said back
at a carfax
sometimes bang bang
bang i've had some juicy back of the
whip [ __ ]
juicy ones so as i do
your thing i'm pretty sure that's what i
said but yeah go on
but so i said
you have no idea how much that resonated
with me bro firstly
there's a huge difference between lust
and potential love the second girl
sounds like she's
she's a good [ __ ] time and if the and
if the first girl was never in the
picture you'd be all over in an instant
but this first girl [ __ ] the first girl
you think she could potentially be wifey
and it's mad
but then you think [ __ ] i could
potentially [ __ ] the second girl
bro there's nothing there's nothing like
[ __ ] in the back
of the car every man needs to do it it's
a tough situation
the only difference with me is the girl
i was [ __ ] in the in the car was my
first girl
in that yeah yeah yeah i was like bro
stick to the first goal
no stick it on the first girl for a bit
for a bit more and see if she responds
maybe she's distracted and got other
guys giving her attention more than you
you never know
but she's still but she still [ __ ] with
you do you feel me
stick it on her and see how she reacts
if she's not giving you the same energy
[ __ ] girl number two in the back of the
car like the real g that you are
fam sometimes
you're bipolar sometimes isn't it
because sometimes
you've got no energy yeah and then
sometimes
you think i'm writing that back you
think i'm writing that back
you gave him time and effort i applaud
you for that because
it resonate with me you used to [ __ ] yes
in the back of your car like no one's
business like
it was exactly like he said he had no
other choice he had no
i wasn't [ __ ] in my parents house
back then he had no other choice
uh that's never resonated i've always
[ __ ] girls in my mom's yard
gang gang well no i tell a lie i haven't
always
um so in fact i probably felt like three
girls there but still
back of whip is is banging that's why i
said it resonated with me
but yeah that's why i had to give out to
go in detail with my own
that's fair play man yeah it's a tough
one like i do
some yeah i kind of agree with you in
terms of like do maybe
push the first one a little bit more not
just not just a [ __ ] but just see what
see what are we saying like what are we
actually saying so because if you see
something with that then
by all means you're willing you should
be willing to try it yeah
yeah yeah yeah make a conscious effort
that he's questioning [ __ ] the second
goal because of the first girl
he must be feeling a lot for this girl
like but like i said in the beginning if
the first girl wasn't in the picture
you'd be banging this second girl
regardless yeah so yeah yeah
yeah it's a catch it's one of them ones
couch 22. yeah man for sure i
agree with you man that's that's a tough
one um
i was thinking this kind of reminds me
of when i was younger as well
that situation i think we spoke about
this before i can't remember
in that when i was young young
i used to actually first first do you
remember your first kiss
have i not spoken about this on it
before i don't think so yes i
do yes i do got one traumatic
going dramatic going and going i feel
like maybe we've spoken right but just
not here because i remember speaking
about this
recently okay and it was definitely in
this yard okay so
i would this was when i was in nigeria
so i was in year eight
okay my i was in boarding school
obviously whoever listened to this knows
i was in board of school
my sister at that time had a boyfriend
yeah
and they had asked me and my girlfriend
at that time in year eight
if we had ever kissed and we said no
because we hadn't
she was and there was like all right
kiss now then oh god
that's such an older sibling thing to do
it was it wasn't even her
it was the boy it was my sister's
boyfriend yeah that makes sense
kiss now then oh that makes perfect
sense
nah cause obviously i wasn't smooth back
then i wasn't i didn't have my heart
would have been beating fam
my blood would have ran cold james
anyway so i was like nah and what they
what they said was all right we'll make
it more easy i'm more comfortable for
you we'll kiss like my sister and the
boyfriend
will kiss and then you kiss after i was
just still staring
i don't think i haven't said anything
i was saying anything i didn't disagree
i didn't agree
i could imagine i was
and i couldn't imagine that i just
pictured your face just
[Music]
just didn't even answer him
on yeah yeah that's [ __ ] funny
i was in such awe in disarray yeah yeah
yeah i was like okay whatever
so they lips and i was like [ __ ] we have
to lips now oh
dear and what made it worse was we
looked at it because we were sitting
down and they were standing up i don't
know why that even matters but that's
that's what was happening so we were we
were sat next to each other we looked at
each other
i took a deep breath and i think
i think because we weren't making a move
they said all right we're gonna count
you down oh stop
three two one kind of thing and he
counted us down and it was just like a
and that fam it was the most
embarrassing
thing i've ever been through
traumatic fam my one actually wasn't too
dissimilar to that
okay so you know
it's weird because you're actually from
london
yeah so this thing doesn't make sense to
you
okay but when you're not from london yes
you've always got a ting
in london right a make-believe girl in
london
every guy who doesn't live in london
knows what i'm talking about all right
so it may not just be london but your
closest big city
okay sorry okay i have no reference of
that fam
so i'm chilling this both happened with
virginity and first kiss okay for
everyone right
so basically this is the game so i'm in
like year eight year nine
yeah and we're having all chin wags and
one thing
called lyan started moving to me
well basically she was at the time she
was like
top two office girls in my year but
i fancied her yeah i fancied her since
year seven
so i mean yeah she was tail one yeah
bragging yeah so she must have been in
my maths class right
um in this i think it was year nine yeah
because i think year nine's when you
start separating a bit more
from like your main you know you've got
your main group that you'd pretty much
do most of your classes with
and then there's certain subjects like
english math and science
you have the you have like the tears
they're tears like who the smartest
levels are
and then you're just with bare people
that are good at maths and better if
you're share sideshow of bear people
[ __ ] yeah
nine years starts at year nine classes
it must have been year nine right so i i
hadn't ellipse the goal
at this point okay so we're chatting
chat in china nia's in my math class and
she's just talking to me
more than regular okay and i'm like cool
i'm here for it yeah
and then one time right she's got a
brethren this
boy called danny so i'm getting changed
after pete one day danny rolls up to me
he's like yo james
um leanne said like she wants to go out
of you in it that she wants to be a
girlfriend
and i was like shut your mouth you lying
prick
and he was i swear down i'm not joking i
was like you're a liar and he was like
i'm i'm swear to god yeah and i was like
well tell her [ __ ] yes yes
a thousand times yes what are you on
about why are you still
don't ask me rhetorical questions she
should have asked you and you should
have said yes for me
but i was so angry i was like in time
she's gonna change your mind
she's obviously gonna change her mind so
hurry up and say yes for me
so he dip said yes and then all of a
sudden yeah we're doing a ting
so i'm like calm so a few days in and
stuff like that my boys are like oh
so you're doing things like yay
whatever whatever most waves are fly um
and they're like cool like have your
lips throw up yet and i was like
nah nah nah and then i was like bro
we've been dating since like yesterday
yeah like i don't even think we've
talked about that we've dated we've not
even said hello today
we're gonna come back yeah yeah we're
gonna come back we haven't even spoke
about it
so i'm like cool and then my boys are
like ah have you ever lost anyone before
because you ain't never i've never seen
your lips
no one and i'm like yeah yeah i've
listings
and they're like who and i was like ah
like
wow one thing in london isn't it and
they're like what i don't know one thing
one thing in london what's her name
right
she queen or something i can't remember
there's betting's betting's in london
kilburn cuban side no no
no off north kilburn yeah then once and
then like i swear sorry i'm like yeah
yeah it's lipstick yeah
bedtimes yeah lipstick fingered it
probably can't come over
i sound these times i'm sweating
and then so i let call call call
and then um a few more days go by
me and leanne still haven't lipped yeah
and now she's talking to gal about it so
obviously this is pre-group chat
so she's doing the real version just
she's group chat
yeah yeah yeah chatting in groups
human form she's forming a cluster
they're chatting yeah and then one thing
who was um one thing who's friends with
me uh her group she's like yo you're
gonna have to lip sleep you know and i'm
like swear down what's going on
what's she saying what's going on what's
she saying she's not feeling mad anymore
i'm stressed fab and then she's like oh
like
she's thinking you've never lipped snow
on before i'm like what why is she
thinking that's like because you have a
lipstick like
a day for like three days like what's
going on
and i'm like oh [ __ ] hell all right
bro yeah
and then so we buck after school so
after school outside the gates
everyone's like saying goodbye to
everything she rolls up to me
gives me a hug and says i'll see you
later and i was like see you later
and then um she was like what can i not
get a kiss nah
fam my heart stopped and you know when
you're in a club and you're shouting
and then the music stops and you're
gonna say that exactly at that point
that's how i felt when she said can i
have a kiss no i felt like everyone has
stopped talking coincidentally at that
one moment
because as soon as she said that
everyone looks at me yeah
and i had a bridge called rob he was
stood
here because we used to walk home
together he was stood here and
he was the most immature bastard of all
time
and he was there beaming teeth
everything up and man's just like
lipstick lipstick
that's it and i'm like egging you off
yeah ellipse lips lose it i'm not stop
my heart i can't explain the panic
every form of panic your body can exude
it was doing it
at that moment yeah sweat [ __ ] my
lips trembling my ass cheeks are
clapping like
i needed to fart pierce everything from
i'm like
cool so fam lips juicy lips
i'm lips in here i must open my eyes and
rob's here though
he can smell our breath he's here
smiling because
and he's here all i can hear his mama
like yeah
yeah but he was horny family
we'll talk about that another day he was
horny that was he was there for it
that's funny i was like yeah but we were
laughing
lipstick and you know what you said
about the other week about
um having the makeup around your face
that's how i had with her lip gloss
okay so my lips were beaming after that
and i was thinking i'm just
swaying over to the mandate like what
yeah yeah yeah what lips yeah
normally yeah come let's go home and i'm
just bowling my lips are glistening
bear glitter bear strawberry glitter
most embarrassing time [ __ ] most
embarrassing time but the reason i
bought the first kiss ting
um actually what was you going to say
before i was going to say the fear of
walking it because
my girlfriend at the time in secondary
school was in my form class
so when i remember asking her i asked
her out on the stairs
she said yes and i ran away as soon as
she said yes i was like gang and
ran away
[Laughter]
i couldn't swallow my water for ages
i can imagine i can imagine
oh my god fun
when you're you you run for no reason
that's just how you get around
and i ran away i can i can see it she
said yeah and i
smiled i was like gang and i ran away
[ __ ] ran away
i was like it's pattern now i don't need
to worry about that yeah
yeah you've got balls i ain't asking
anyone but then obviously
we're in the same form yeah so every
time every time i used to come into
class if she was there before me
i'm panicked because then i have i now
have to make the choice of
do i sit next to her or do i sit where i
normally sit with a mandem
oh yeah so i don't sing next to her do i
just say hi while i go
and then go to maneuver to where my boys
are i see where i normally sit
or if i do sit next to her would
everyone be like
you know yeah and it's just like big man
i'm in here
nine year 10. leave me alone i don't
have this
i don't i can't i can't i can't function
with this kind of pressure i can't
function
yeah it's so annoying yeah so if i'm if
i get there before her i'm
gassed i'm happy yeah she has so many
choices
her problem what would she sit next to
me or not is her problem
and we hadn't i don't think we had lips
for time i can't remember my first lips
with her yeah but like i said i remember
my first ever lips yeah yeah but the
whole that whole pressure thing in a
form room
ah i'm sorry i'm so happily i was not in
my phone
but the next day and luckily luckily for
me
in maps because she's been chirping me
up she'd already decided to start they
sit next to me okay so when we were in
the next math class
once we were together yeah we were
always next to each other anyway
so it was fine it was a relief but
moving forward we must have been dating
for like i don't know
it could have been six months it could
have been two weeks i really don't know
yeah you know i mean in school time
nothing makes sense yeah um
so me was i can't describe you at that
time yeah i know because i could
probably
find her now i'll show you a picture in
your blog yeah like i don't know
29 year old woman i don't even know what
she looks like exactly as a kid i know
exactly what
i fancied her more than i'd had ever
fancied anyone in my entire life
cheating wasn't a concept
it wasn't even in my head it wasn't even
in my head
but that brings me to my next point so
the relationship's in full swing yeah
and there's another yet so remember i
said
i had an insider who was telling me
feeding me information
inside man inside yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah so feeding me
yes me and her were boys
yeah my name was justine right we were
boys
and she was cool we used to chat all the
time and she was she was good looking
and stuff like she was a white girl
right and then um
so we were chilling chilling and one
time this is how you know girls are
[ __ ] snakes
i've got a story as well and so you know
girls are [ __ ] snakes so
one other girl from their group
must have run to me one day she's like
what's going on with julian and i'm like
what do you mean
she's i was like what's going on
obviously you're together like how's it
going and i'm like cool man that's true
she was like cool
maybe she's a bit annoying now do you
think likely is a bit annoying and i'm
like no
she's fine she was like hmm what did you
figure justine
and i was like yeah she's cool let me
hear her boys i swear down slow down
i think she passes you and i was like
what she's like yeah i think she likes
you isn't it do you like her and i'm
like
these times i'm thinking i'm in a
relationship yeah
[Applause]
i don't know what you're asking me
i'm in a relationship like what she
means do i fancy her like
of course i don't fancy anyone but like
no one else yeah like
what do you mean
and then she's like oh swear well
uh justine fancies you in here you
should do a thing and i'm like again i'm
like i'm
taken like i'm off them yeah i'm off the
market like what do you mean and they're
basically married at that yeah yeah yeah
and then she's all right cool well
obviously i've fed you the information
the ball's in your court so this is
another thing this is another thing
it's just been a spiteful little [ __ ]
um
and uh she's [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] up
the fun
um and at this point i think she just
had a tiff of leanne
and she's like i'm trying to [ __ ] leah's
life up that's what i actually think was
happening
so these times i'm going home now and
i'm stressed
i don't know what to do yeah and i'm
banging up
[ __ ] um these are the times
i used to force myself to feel songs so
i'm going home i'm locking myself in my
room
i'm turning on my walkman headphones
here
and i'm just you made me want to leave
them with
a new relationship i'm like why am i in
this predicament
i'm on my knees crying
why is god doing this to me
test of time fam and i'm just here five
minutes
that's such a chew it is [ __ ] i was
dancing found all the moves
and then boy i remember they were
putting over the next few days they were
putting so much pressure on me to dump
this lianting
that i made the biggest mistake of my
life and actually crumbled in her
dumpster
really i just said i don't think it's
working out kind of thing and i never
actually even ended up doing a thing
with justine yeah
i never just removed the pressure of it
because you were boys anyway
and i found her attractive and stuff
like that we were just boys but it was
literally just the pressure of it
they they basically talked to me into it
yeah and then once
i dumped her they didn't give a [ __ ] if
i got with justine or not
they didn't give a single [ __ ] they were
just happy that they got where they
wanted what was your relationship with
justine after the dump
fine the exact same as it was before
oh wow nothing changed oh wow we're a
little bit more flirty maybe
but nothing ever changed but then as
soon this is this is probably where it
started for me of me wanting yachts that
i can't have
because as soon as i dumped leanne i
remember me and my boys went to play
tennis
the next day at one leisure center was
we're playing tennis and she rocks up
with her friends
and she's looking fire she was looking
fine i remember what she was wearing
she was wearing a pink track suit a
suede looking thing
she was wearing a pink pink tracy i
already knew it was suede i already knew
it was suede i
like a baby factory yes and it was
looking fresh over the shoulder
everything
she was looking back and i was thinking
what have i
done
and i remember trying to text her that
night she was not interested cause
and i was just like
i'm such an idiot that's what it all
started for me but yeah what's gonna say
about spiteful [ __ ] so
whilst i was obviously i was dating this
chicken yeah this was in year 10 when i
was dating the chick and i don't
remember
what i don't remember what happened in
terms of us breaking up
or something like that but when you said
oh there's another there's jigsaw
there's oh there's another chick that
likes you kind of thing
i found out there was another chick that
liked me and again there was no whatsapp
group
there was a group so i found because
they were all friends they were girls
well
quote-unquote girls and there was a
chick
i don't want to say her name there was a
chick and she
she was at that time
had the most banging tits and banging
arse and flat stomach
in our year yeah yeah i didn't
understand
how someone in year 10 can have that
body yeah yeah yeah yeah i was thinking
if you like me i have to pat on you yeah
do you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah
bear in mind my actual girlfriend had
the
she was like the same way you thought um
what's the name leanne was the most
banging thing you've seen it's the same
way i felt about my goal at the time and
her
ass bro i didn't
i was still i was still a virgin then
yes oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah i lost my vagina when i was
17. yeah i was probably about 14 15 then
15 i think i i was i'm still a virgin
so sex was in my head but it wasn't
like the forefront of our relationship
yeah yeah yeah we were just enjoying
ourselves yeah
yeah yeah yeah grab him i used to
squeeze
leon got squeezed up her james
her bum was so i couldn't fathom it she
was kenyan
father and it was such a contradictory
concept because kenyans are normally
skinny
well back at anyway anyway so there's
another chick
her physique was unreal unreal
yeah yeah yeah and the thing the thing
was every man wanted to [ __ ] her
yeah yeah and it was one bread i would
have died for her
i don't want to hide him up because he
listens to this he was a white guy he
knows who he is
he was the only he was one of the only
one or two white guys in our
like circle of demanding oh swear yeah
yeah he knows who he is
i don't want to say his name
coincidentally he's engaged now and he's
going to get to a black girl
oh gang gang gang gang gang gang gang
props
props um he he would have died for her
so when he found out that she was
feeling me
yeah i think he asked me oh have you man
done a thing yeah obviously at the time
i said no because i hadn't done it yeah
yeah but i think me and my girlfriend at
the time were having a little
squad ball i can't remember what
happened yeah but it then
veered me towards the other yacht yeah b
and then i remember i think i
walked home or something we never had
sex i walked home
but we lipped and i fingered the christ
out of her
i fingered the christ out of here we
just let god remember she was wearing a
tracksuit
her oh my hands are smaller then i grips
her ass like
like i squeeze it like play-doh was
coming out
how soft it was it felt like play-doh
was coming out through the gaps of my
fingers
i couldn't fathom it yeah because prior
to that i hadn't squeezed any other spot
my girls
do you know what i mean so it felt so
different firm
the next [ __ ] day my girl came up to
me i was like
i don't think i don't think was having
the next day could have been that week
or like a couple weeks after
she was like i don't think we're working
out blah blah blah i just want to look
i'm and i'm thinking
why why why she's like oh i had a dream
that you and this other girl did a thing
and it made me feel some type of way
and that's when i first realized i
didn't think i realized then
but i think i realized after the fact
that one yes don't give a [ __ ]
regardless of the same circle because
when she had told me i remember
specifically that you might have been
chilling recently yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so how how are you chilling
with her yeah yeah yeah but vex at me
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it just it that's when the
whole thing popped for me like
yats don't care they don't that was the
initial yachts don't care moment for me
they don't when you said about you
squeeze her up and lipstick
fam there was one time when i knew
nothing of like you said
sex was on my mind yeah but it was not
the forefront of my brain
i remember i remember where i was i was
outside a dumpster it was near a yard it
was
because that was the only secluded area
she lived in a flat and we were by like
where the
trash
oh i remember her breath on my ear oh my
god foreigner
ah i'm jealous because you got more than
what i did in a similar situation yeah
so after our dumb liar now
yeah this is probably a month or two
down the line maybe even longer yeah so
this is the the flame has died
yeah yeah so we're i'm i still fancy the
[ __ ] over there yeah
i'm about to walk out i needed a haircut
right so i'm about to walk into town
to get this trim after school and she
hollered me and she lived in the
opposite direction for down so
she was kind of walking like in my
direction
and then she was like oh where are you
going and i was i'm going to town and
get trimmed
she was like cool i'm going down this
world do you mind if i walk with you and
i was like no
come come so this is post breakout this
is way post breakup okay okay
so we're walking walking walking talking
talking laughing laughing and i said oh
i just need to get some money from my
yard
and my yard was on the way to town
anyway so she was like that's fine
so we go to um
we go to my yard and
we're in there and my mom's not home my
brother's not home
no one's home and fam we get to my yard
i go in
she comes in go in and it's gonna be a
quick like i'm just gonna run up get the
cash and we'll go she's like cool
fam close the door lock the door turn
around and she's like here
and she's like leaned up against the
wall and she's staring at me
and in my head i'm like right
i'm gonna ellipse this girl pick her up
carry up to my room
and we're gonna [ __ ] and it's gonna be
the greatest day of my [ __ ] life
like the sexual tension in this moment
is too much
i'm like 14 15. and i'm like this is it
this is it
this is it fam we're there they're there
she's staring at him she didn't say
anything she didn't blink my heart will
shut up fam
my heart's racing like my palms are so
sweaty and
literally we were this close
and i couldn't move and i was like
okay it's just upside down i could get
it [ __ ] the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out to this day i don't
know what would have happened
she could have been like what the [ __ ]
are you doing or she could have been
down for it down i remember like it was
yesterday fam i'm talking about
something that was 14 years ago
i remember like it was yesterday she
stared at man and she was looking
piff
i just ran upstairs
[Laughter]
i ran upstairs with my wallabies and my
boner fam
i was gonna say my dick would have been
so hard my dick was solid i had to wait
upstairs till it subsided
and i was just like what's wrong with
you bro i was pacing in my room
like what's something wrong with you bro
i was so angry at myself you know when
you grab a pillow and scream into it
that was me and i'm just like why am i
such a
[ __ ] do something be a man for once in
your life
bro and the moment's gone and there's no
getting it back you can't
revive that sam you can't revive the
peak thing is
this is the [ __ ] anointing after that
you can tell that was like the optimal
moment because after that
nothing ever happened again and then
once we left school
in year 11 i never saw her again and we
never spoke or anything like that and
she was always my what if girl
cowinky dinky two years later so i'm
like 18 now
19. before you say this you've spoken
about lyan before
is this is this the chick that you said
walked past your yard or something
that used to walk past you to go to
college no no no
okay that was banging no no no no no no
no no okay that was lauren
okay okay okay okay she was a team
because you think i had her in my head
i don't because obviously you spoke
about lauren before but obviously i
didn't know the blog
was a dream girl that's okay okay sorry
sorry sorry screams
sorry that's jokes that's jokes renting
lauren yeah
renting yeah yeah um so yeah yeah right
whole thing just dwindled into nothing
she was just another girl at school at
this point okay
fast forward two years yeah um
i'm chilling with a boy we're playing
basketball but boy uh who used to play
basketball et cetera et cetera and he's
talking to me about like
um of this girl that he's started seeing
and then just like
oh how they beat and it was banging and
like he took a virginia
stuff he'd be at this point he beat
betting and stuff like that and then
he's like oh i took a virginia
they were dating all this stuff and i
was like he was like yeah we're playing
basketball tomorrow so like
i'll bring her true fam i was playing
playing playing i look up
and it's her it's liane and she rocks in
and then i don't know what it was in
that moment because i didn't care i
hadn't seen her in like two years yeah
or whatever
and even after that we'd still spend the
rest of the school
time together without anything i didn't
care anymore found but soon she walked
in
and knowing what he'd just told me about
this special girl that he was now dating
and i saw it was her and i was just like
that could have been me that could have
been me what transpired when
you saw each other at that moment just
banners
just like a little like acknowledgement
but i think she
knew what she was walking into i didn't
know okay because
he would have told me yeah he would have
spoken i'm sorry i'm sure
because he did he knew she went my
school because he didn't go to our
school he went to another school so
he knew that she went to my school so
she he probably would have
briefed her and said oh like come true
i'm playing with james and then
oh you might know james because she i
know she knew what she was walking into
because she played cool as a cucumber
and you just had to play the role i just
played a role and i was just like
why go on and then like after that i was
so deflated
only for like 10 minutes i know what you
mean though but in that one moment
i was like oh what are the odds
what are the [ __ ] odds of all the
girls brav
had to be my one that got away [ __ ] that
i threw away
when i was a fourteen-year-old you
literally literally ran away
like a scared baby oh it was a [ __ ]
nightmare bro
i really really regretted it back then
because that moment
sorry bro i could have been the start of
something special anyway
moving on but yeah renting lauren
she was a different breed she was my she
was my
make-believe bae that the only backstory
was
from her was because like i said where i
went to school was literally like a mile
walk
from where i lived my catchment school
was
on my doorstep so laurenting
went to a school called ren that's why i
call her renting she went to that school
and would have to walk past my house on
her way home every day so
literally from my first day in year
seven to my last day in year 11. yeah
i saw her every single day yeah i
remember you saying blossoming
blossoming and ah forever every single
day i was like that is the most
banging girl i've ever seen in my life
that's crazy
and then obviously yeah whatever
transpired that my boy [ __ ] me over
and stuff like that but yeah
yeah yeah that was wild work
those were the good old days [ __ ]
they were fun those are fun days man
i have not thought about secondary
school in a while i never thought about
first kiss and blah blah i've not
thought about something
i don't ever think about it i don't
remember asking that girl out and
running away until we had this
conversation
the amount of stuff that people must
think that i've just got this
ready to shoot yeah this catalog of
everything i've just told you
i have not thought about since it
happened
of course and i'm bringing it up like it
was yesterday i don't know why i
remember i remember
squeezing this girl's ass like it was
played like it was yesterday her ass was
she had the most banging body the
most for her age i couldn't fathom it
there was no one top enough his equis
god damn it there was no one topping her
physique wise uh i remember yeah fran
when the when the yes started blossoming
in school
it was a different breed it caught me at
the worst time when i'm dealing with my
own hormones
i don't need this yeah i don't need this
i don't need titties and batteries to
start growing when
when i'm dealing with my own [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was tough boy boners were long
they were long um you said you had the
assault thing
i've got an mio there also today um it's
from a fan
i just need to find it
all right
boom
cool yeah so my best mate has this crush
i think it's a bit honest what we've
been talking about my best [ __ ] i
remember it now
my best mate has this crush who goes on
about
wait so my best mate has this crush who
he goes on about
but he always says he'd never have the
chance with her
and if she was to get with any of us he
wouldn't mind
but kind of drops hints that he'd be
pissed in a subtle way
so he gets mixed vibe and he put in
brackets she's 10 10 by the way she's a
badass
and the opportunity came to an
opportunity
to beat came my way okay and i had to
take it oh
now he's pissed at me and doesn't want
to be my mate anymore
am i the [ __ ]
right i've actually had this exact same
conversation with someone recently where
it's like
it's a little bit more like what we said
about the technicalities of stuff
like he did say
it's fair game but clearly this guy's
read the room
and knows that he's saying one thing but
he's feeling another it means completely
the other thing yeah
like i know
it's not really relevant to us um
because oh [ __ ] we would never really
get stuck in this
this there's too many hoes out there
that's one thing people need to
understand
young people don't get it yeah there's
too many there's more than enough hosts
for everyone
there's options there's more than enough
[ __ ] for everyone but anyway young
people will never get what i'm saying
they don't get at that time they don't
get it at the time they think that like
options
every possibility you have to capitalize
which in some instances you kind of do
but um you'll learn later off in life
there's
there's more opportunities than you can
count okay and
he is a dick he is an [ __ ] yeah
because
granted he said yeah my boy said he
wouldn't care if any of us smash
but you've openly acknowledged that you
care
you [ __ ] care so you shouldn't have
smashed
i don't know and the game is the game
and the other day you made your
objective you made your bed you got to
sleep in it
you knew it was the wrong thing to do
you knew it was the wrong thing to do
but hard dick is impossible to control
i'm not judging you that's another yeah
i'm not judging you yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah not judging you at
all as well hard dick is pos impossible
to control especially when in
their opinion she's at 10 10 yeah in
that instant or in that moment
she's feeling you you can't what
situation are they in that i don't know
what situation are they in that this
banging thing at
any given moment could [ __ ] anyone in
this group and the opportunity flew my
way and i had to grab it like who is
this girl
dear you know who you are when you
listen to this so dm me this girl please
yeah yeah yeah yeah show me
send us the pic send us the send us the
girl i mean i want to read i want to
know what scenario it is that she just
the [ __ ] is available on a certain day
at a certain time and whoever's there at
this time
needs to snatch it [ __ ] hell but
yeah just a living a different this
isn't the same as when we were kids
it's not the same as when we were kids i
ran away from my girlfriend
we literally just said we ran away from
our girls 100 and these men are just
collecting vagina
yeah fam [ __ ] um but yeah
yes in my opinion you are the [ __ ]
you should have read the room
you did read you did read the room
you've openly acknowledged that you knew
it wasn't what he said
but he did it anyway so yeah you've
answered your own question right you're
an [ __ ] but
i also think from the and
his boy's perspective he he did say
obviously i wouldn't feel a certain type
of way if whatever happens happens
but even though deep down he did he
should have just been honest that's
another thing
he should have said with his chest i
don't want you to [ __ ] a certain girl
i'm going to tell you big man
don't [ __ ] this girl bruv do me a solid
simple as
simple as because there's so much
potential out there there's so many
options out there
but obviously i i don't know how old
this guy is or whatever i don't know
what their status is at the moment so
they may think this is all i've got
right now dad when what's
when that's all you've got right now
you're taking it
so in that in that instance i understand
so like we said before i understand
we're not judging i understand but you
just said he doesn't even want to be
boys anymore that's
tough man so if you should have known
that prior to [ __ ]
you should have known that if whoever in
this group
[ __ ] this girl that my boy is feeling
he's definitely gonna fall at me you
would have known that by his body
yeah by the way he said it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you did [ __ ] up you are the [ __ ] i'm
not judging you because hard dick is
impossible to control especially if
she's 10 out of 10 which no one is by
the way
um so yeah we're getting another day
it's physically impossible it's
physically impossible 10 out of 10.
no one said outside but in your eyes
she's banging understandable
but this is your boy man you should
never ever ever
don't break the bro don't break the bro
code you should never break the bro code
not for vagina not for vagina and vagina
is exquisite
but bro being a bro is the best
having a boy that you have to talk about
stuff like that with is the most
priceless thing this probably is very
applies like i said i've said on this
podcast probably about 20 episodes ago
a bond between men is hard to break yeah
i know so many females that have had so
many quote unquote best friends and
they've [ __ ] fallen out yeah yeah
had one argument and it wasn't even an
argument oh yeah exactly we laughed
about it
five seconds later and that's it do you
know what i mean
bro it's hard it's hard to find that
you don't want to throw it away word of
advice word of advice guys
don't throw away your boys your
relationship or your friendship with
your boy
over a girl and vice versa girls don't
do that either yeah definitely don't do
that either and yeah another point
like in that like oh the opportunity
came and i had to take it
it does feel like that in the moment in
the moment but trust me there's
so many times that you're going to be
smashing girls so many times so many
millions of times your opportunities
you're going to have to [ __ ] girls you
have no idea yes
but trust me it's kind of and probably
your concept of a 10 out of 10 now is
not true 10 out of 10.
it's not true because my girl when i was
year 10 i
was convinced she was 10 out of 10 until
i squeezed that play-doh booty
until i squeeze that play-doh bomb ah
that's my world changed
my world changed yeah man [ __ ] out
all right rapidly grappity rap
rap see you guys another time